[Music]
welcome to the lobby's GameSpot's first
ever alternative game of the Year awards
just kidding it's mainly the lobby our
last episode of the year of 2017 season
finale you might say I'm your host
Michael Hardy here with Peter Brown as
always your coffee nearly spilled and
Laurie oh hi how are you and Kelly buggy
hello I have the awards here in our
envelopes just to clarify up front this
has nothing to do with a our game of the
Year awards here at GameSpot we did
finish our deliberations but that's like
coming out next week starting we've
already got our report cards and our
year-end review videos going up and
we'll have our full countdown from our
number 10 game to our number 1 game
starting on December 11th we'll have a
full schedule going up have we announced
it's like publicly that we're not doing
25 this year we are now we're not doing
25 this year
Pete you explain yeah so we are you know
where to look anymore we're doing a top
10 instead of top 25 which lets us like
really just dig down and nail like what
really were the best games of the year
but every editor producer at GameSpot
will also get their editors pick so
everyone gets a chance to highlight a
game that maybe didn't fall into that
ball that did not fall into that top 10
and they get to champion that so there's
no hemming and hawing over what's 23 vs.
19 did you say that we still have like
platform Awards as well I did not
Michael McCarty we do still have
platform awards for PlayStation 4 Xbox
one whatever consoles care about PC VR
and mobile that out there it's a far
better way of doing game of the year I
think and like having gone through it
for the most part like you really get to
like narrow down 10 amazing it's more
like digestible I feel like for someone
right like yeah 25 games I feel like
some point you're just sifting through
I'm only time to play 25 here 10 like
you get to like look at each one like
like for longer I feel like I can
actually think about you know is
something I want to dig into I do have a
giveaway last of the year I'll announce
it later on as always she will be
putting it up later on the show and you
can retweet
GameSpot's twitter can I actually just
go to follow GameSpot's twitter account
if you don't already so you'll be ready
for the end of the show to get in on
that randomly picked lottery giveaway
all right cool
so let's get right into these awards so
here's how I smell oh my god me and John
Luke are kind well actually I don't know
let me preface this by saying this I
don't know what do you say inside I just
know what the awards are I don't know
who won them all but I'm gonna hand them
out like I don't know if you guys
watched nor McDonald live he just hands
like pre-written jokes to people and
they have to read them so you are forced
to read these okay so I'll probably
start with Callie I'd say but for the
first five are like best of awards and
again these are have nothing to game of
your awards and they're not all gonna be
that funny some of them actually makes
sense in fact I can't promise that even
won't be funny to you people watching so
I don't know what the hell's that kind
of like super your book superhero
superlatives like cutest couple most
likely most likely succeed most
intellectual you could probably pick out
most intellectual already class clown is
here but for all intents purposes again
this has no bearing over GameSpot's
overall opinion taste or general sense
of credibility
sweet and then we're gonna talk about
the lobby cast favorite like underrated
games of the year maybe not maybe not
under ADA but once we would love to have
talked about more if such a great year
of games didn't happen and unfortunately
overshadow other stuff alright first
award Callie I'll let you read off the
back and then well Gianluca sitting back
I think he's got some some stuff ready
to go and the award for the best version
of Skyrim goes to sound effects no I
think you can go okay
skirt on PC oh oh [ __ ] there's Master
Chief on Skyrim on PC have you guys
played Skyrim on switch or VR is there
still not the best version of it as like
a time portal whereas you've just got
the future and thrown into this I could
watch that for everything that was
amazing there have it Skyrim PC still
kind of the best way to play at game
does really matter that came out in six
other platforms this time Rob next award
read it out and then read out the winner
Oh
why am I not surprised and the best
XCOM two expansions oh [ __ ] this is
stiff comp and the award goes to oh my
god I can't believe it
it's the War of the chosen oh my god yes
holy [ __ ] y'all Luke did you write this
you have no idea hey Eric or Richard
could someone come in here and turn the
volume up a little bit cuz I think we're
not hearing these sound effects and I
want the cast to enjoy these things as
much as I am sweet
so best ex-con to expansion goes to war
that chosen I wish I could talk about
the other ones but I don't we don't have
time so we're just gonna go to war the
chosen what so none of that was XCOM
yeah the children of anarchy an turkeys
children you can like make him look like
a punk thanks Pete here you go this is a
long one the best open-world game that
wasn't breath of the wild or horizon
zero dawn it goes to Assassin's Creed
origins maybe in any other year would
have gotten the best open-world game but
I seem like I'm making fun this games I
really like it's game sweet I'm gonna
why do you like this game Michael
alright alright I got I'll do the next
one are those old dead bodies yeah cribs
oh that's why you likes the game here we
go then the award for best battle royale
game no that's not even I'm not getting
into that one alright Bob you'll like
this one
oh no it's kind of obvious and the award
for the best Star Wars game goes to oh
my god
Star Wars for Serina I had to Google
that Zana congratulations on Android
Play Android play it's like a MOBA I
think I didn't I've never played it I
don't think any of us have but it's not
the best one it's not battlefront 2 it's
got you know flipping in it so you know
yeah so really wanted your Star Wars
fixed that's probably the best was that
touch mean yeah
that's your best bet know whose turn is
it mine Kelly give you the next one now
we're getting into the yearbook
superlatives and most likely to succeed
ghosts you
SuperMario Odyssey yeah I figured that
was fitting for me again I didn't write
these but you know it's moon anywhere
he's just charming Oh find success yeah
everybody loves everyone everywhere
would find success I could see it on
just
like a startup well it's not kidding
it's charming it's got some business
acumen there's not many flaws to it that
wasn't as much of a joke that was
actually just the game that made the
most sense I again I didn't write these
but if I did I forgot what this one was
so this guy interesting klaus clown come
on come on
class clown class clown class clown oh
[ __ ]
Mass Effect Andromeda oh [ __ ] that was
me with facial expressions clowns not an
insult it's it's not at all it's it's
just like it's got it's got confidence
its I kind of can sometimes sometimes to
its own detriment no mass spectrometer
apparently it's a better game now it
might interrupt your class time oh
you're doing
I think surgeon yeah this one's actually
kind of okay and the award for most
intellectual goes to Oh near automatic
yeah I don't know everybody talks about
this game I was mostly saying that
everybody who talks where this game
can't like not sound pretentious I
really like Nier automata but I'm not
gonna talk about it because that would
be hypocritical but yeah this games
great narrative Lee it's you know we
talked about it it actually is one of
the few games that encourages you to do
multiple playthroughs I'd say well not
one of the few games but I felt like it
actually made me want to based on how it
changed I want to experiment with
fashion yeah majors you just wanna
cosplay they're also pretty smart for
you know possessing the ability to walk
around blindfolded that's true that's
that's intellect takes intellect okay
the award for cutest couple goes to I'm
really excited to see this one yeah
Pub G and fortnight Battle Royale when
pub G 1 every argument and everybody
congratulations for tonight Battle
Royale just trying to be as much like
your girlfriend as possible we know
she's more popular than you and we know
that everybody likes her more but you
just had to just follow in her wake and
live in her shadow maybe even this one's
good Oh most likely to come back and
teach at this school in your yearbook I
literally searched your book
superlatives and there's like a list
there's like best best yeah my dad like
most likely to flunk most likely to
president yeah it's over wait this one's
all negative stuff most likely to come
back and teach at this school goes to
call of duty WWE times you try you just
cannot get rid of this person they are
purposefully flunking they are purposely
flunking every goddamn year and don't
just graduate and then get a teacher
teaching degree and come back you can
live here the rest of your life until
you're retired enough tenure okay I'm
gonna make you read this one I think you
could sell it because it's time to beam
and the award for most likely to
actually not be graduating today goes to
will it go oh wow
waaah breaker I'll just let the b-roll
know exactly that's not true because
this is a fun game but like 12 really
but it's that student that everybody
loved but then like no I was gonna just
say something that's the next joke
actually no this one's good
okay all right get right to the next one
John Luke thank you that's all I had to
say about libraries a fantastic game I
really like it I just didn't play much
like most people all right
most likely to ask you to borrow money
next goes to Star Wars Battlefront I'm
not even good to me talk about not
kicking it when it's down but yeah if
you see people people are excited for
them we wish we could say more about
this game but I'm actually just not
looking forward to paying another
another $60 news news get a part-time
job
sure newsflash they apparently raised
all the the amount of like currency and
experience you get in this game I'm just
interested to see like like what to what
extend you're getting more stuff however
do you playing more and no thanks Rob I
just heard that and I was like oh cool
they're doing something I think I'm
missing one but I remember the joke and
once John man from Nantucket jean-luc
this is stop me if I'm like Rena sellout
but it is that person that you went to
school with and then forgot about and
then at the five-year reunion you have
to try to remember their name to no
avail
and the award all right it was drawn to
death don't yell at us no one knows the
drawn to death is that's the person that
you forever name okay oh this is that
you got this one right see read this one
really sell it David Jaffe okay sorry
about my handwriting I mean that
person's handwriting I don't know who
are these no it's it's somewhat legible
most likely to show up on a reality TV
show with hair plugs and an iron
deficiency yeah and the award goes to
agents of melody Rob I knew you'd like
that one
that's great yeah we'll see you you'll
be smashing with Snooki on season 13
what is the culture ashore NIC
margaritas hi that's the that's the last
yearbook superlative thank you for the
b-roll jean-luc apologize for not having
drawn to death I think we just couldn't
find it year old for it and that was the
problem because it was one more just as
jean-luc and it's scribbled out what so
it doesn't it says the best game ever
made that like everybody should love I
don't know what who wrote this one dude
who wrote this goddamn X come pray so
that was pretty much the lobby's as much
fanfare as we could with that little
effort as possible and that's what
happened all right now let's move on to
our the lobby cast wrapping up the year
in games were those two mean it was the
best of times it was the worst of times
but mainly that's pretty accurate
those two mean yeah probably yeah
Battlefront I don't even feel bad about
but anyway I want to go around to people
I asked you like pick two games out for
that again that we didn't really I mean
we talked about in the lobby I'm sure
but we wanted to talk about more all
throughout the year again this has no
bearing on GameSpot's overall game d
rewards this is just us for because
we've been hanging out all year this
isn't a vacuum yes yeah so do not
associate we're trapped in here please
help I'm gonna start with you Callie
what is like one game that you think
more people should have been talking
about all throughout the year because it
was really really good or that you
played a shit-ton off I really want to
spotlight night in the woods which is a
game that I reviewed and I didn't
actually get to talk about much on the
lobby came out way earlier in the year
yeah
lead into the faeces that's what I have
to action for all you people watching
you heard it like and subscribe now
Kelly thank it was this game I think I
didn't give didn't get the attention it
deserves I think it blends really funny
writing with a mix of very you know
contemporary issues so it's not just
about one thing it's not just about like
20-somethings having a hard time it's
also about the shrinking middle class
about you know the late capitalism
you know existential crisis kind of
stuff and about depression and I think
it blends those things well and does a
good job of integrating those issues
together in a way that's not
overwhelming but still highly effective
and without being depressing because
it's actually very very funny so people
are like that it captures a Midwestern
vibe really well I grew up in upstate
New York and it actually captured that
too yeah kind of middle-class suburban
American absolutely it's a yeah for me
it made me think of the Midwest just
because I have family there so that's
just like what my connection is but I
think it's more Universal than that kind
of a comes out of left field like how
serious that game gets cuz I didn't
expect it to I played I only played like
half of it but even at that point it got
to the point where I was
I don't know based on the aesthetic and
whatnot like I know people like to care
because I didn't really like the main
character but I did like a surrounding
cast he wasn't that pants please the
main character in many ways reminded me
of myself when I was like 19 in that
know that's the thing is like I was
really depressed and I didn't really
have like a personality outside of being
depressed and there's a conversation she
have their mom pretty early on that's
basically almost word-for-word a
conversation I had with my mom and so
that's what drew me into her but I think
the supporting characters there's
there's just a lot of like standout
moments for me there's a this one
character who read
poetry and normally it's really stupid
and she kind of has this one breakout
poem that's really impactful there's
many games like this kind of right I'll
see you what remains of you the Finch I
do really like how the minigames are
integrated because they're silly and
they they give personality to the
characters and they kind of give you a
break because there were times where I
really needed a break from this game
because I was getting very I don't wanna
say like it was depressing because it
wasn't but I was kind of like
disassociating playing it because it was
just like so it was so much at once and
the minigames do break that up a lot
there's the Italian restaurant in this
game there's a weird segue
that's called pastabilities yeah a great
name but also be again the name of an
Italian restaurant in Syracuse New York
really yeah like I had to look up
whether these people were from around
Syracuse I think they're from Canada
right like Toronto or something they're
from is it Pennsylvania yes somewhere
burg Pittsburgh think yeah that makes
sense
but yeah overall the this is a great
game from when I played it's actually
longer than I thought it would be it is
a lot longer it probably took me like 12
hours but that's also like there were
times where I just kind of had to like
step away and process everything yes I
especially compared to like what remains
of eve's Finch I can always trip up
saying that what remains of Edith Finch
took me like an hour and a half and
they're not like the same game but
they're kind of in the same vein like a
narrative leave focus I would call this
more of an adventure game than a like I
think Edith Finch's a straight up
narrative game and I I don't think
they're as comparable as like I don't
think they're comfortable at all in many
ways just because they they're both
narrative focus I think they are very
different like very different tones and
Edith Finch has much narrower scope than
this yeah yeah sure yeah and there's a
mini game it's hard as hell
it's weird as someone I'm assuming some
was playing this might actually be my
capture it was like oh yeah you join a
band at one point wait what are you the
guitarist or the bassist looks like a
guitar okay no that's actually I guess
yeah well yes maybe that's four strings
it is basically
wasn't in the woods that released
earlier in the year from mark mm-hmm
writer it's been so long really
in the year who reviewed that for us do
you member me you did reveal I said that
at the start oh I thought you were
saying it's a great list because you
know I remember listening but I'm saying
like didn't get to talk about in the
lobby too much so I was like oh is that
before you joined GameSpot or something
I need it but we there was other stuff
to talk about so cool all right Rob what
is one of the two games that you want to
talk about called little game called
echo echo echo a former hitman devs oh
god damn it
yeah for my hitman devs this is their
first game remind me what their what
their I'll light up again their new
company's called oh it's like a hyper
trap anyways this game was just a
surprise for me I am such a huge sci-fi
fan and every bit of this aesthetic is
just gripping and playing this I just I
just hit every chord for me and the main
drive is the fact that you know for
those who don't know you are you going
from you know you land on this alien
planet and the enemies are essentially
clones of yourself and the game goes
through cycles light cycles they call
them which is one right now in between
our dark cycles and a light cycle will
basically record all of your actions and
movement and play styles and in the next
light cycle will feed them into these
clones of yourself so the model of the
game is like you know you're playing
against yourself yeah it's it's really
it's different I don't I can't point to
any game that I feel like captures that
idea so well where you have like such
tense moments like this where you can't
just go around shooting everyone or like
also incorporating stealth into one
cycle because then the next cycle
they're gonna be implementing both of
those play styles so you find yourself
in like tense moments where like you you
slip you you mess up you shoot too much
you just have this sense of gravity of
for this next cycle which is going to be
so difficult and sure enough it is and
the level design is really neat to where
they you know where my favorites was you
walk into room you see all these clones
and in doors and they're in cages
they're just looking at you but they
don't know how to open doors
so yeah all right cool I'll just breeze
past them and then there's a door in
front of you and then you realize I open
this door
oh by the way these cages are like
following down a hallway so they're just
following you but they're separating
between two cages and then you realize I
open this door they're gonna come out
and they're gonna chase me and when
there is when there's more than three of
these clowns you're done you're screwed
because they take you down immediately
and it's just these there are plenty of
moments just like that where the game is
like using like level design and
different like mechanics each kind of
each stage or level as it goes on and I
just had a blast playing it is ultra
ultra ultra I think I believe they're in
Copenhagen yeah and then second thing I
was reading a rally McCloud he's about
one of the writers over at Kotaku was
writing about this game kind of around
the same time you were talking about you
- I remember like hearing you talk about
and looking it up and I see Riley over
it Kotaku had been championing it he
said at some points it almost makes him
feel like an NPC might because like an a
like a an AI NPC might because of the
fact that they don't have many powers
until like you use them feels like
they're escalating alongside you but
it's also kind of power fantasy yeah
like the more powers you use the more
you have to deal with it and it's just
kind of got this inherently built-in
sense of difficulty scaling which you
know ya know for sure that's that's
actually a really cool observation
because absolutely like you you don't
take for granted when you play a lot of
games of like what you're actually doing
mm-hmm
and it's everything it's crouching it's
you know it's vaulting it's you again
shooting opening doors why you when have
you ever play the game where you like
are like trying not to you're conscious
about that you're trying not to open
doors or opening too many
you're just you're I've never had a game
like this kind of work your brain in a
very different way the stealth takedowns
are terrifying I mean using them is one
thing but then knowing that the enemy
they can do it to you yeah the UI is
really nice here like all the sort of
like systems that are surrounding your
territory
that's the idea that that cube is
actually holding like a person that
you're trying to rescue is a neat little
yeah thing like you're constantly
shepherding around this person in
distress yeah yeah that the narrative is
pretty strong I I definitely enjoy it
you're kind of talking to a an AI
throughout the voice actor is I was
forget her name
you know from a Whoopi Goldberg ingridt
okay cool oh yes stop bringing up these
this trivia from from what I know it
what's her name from Ingrid from Game of
Thrones
oh yes her so much stop stealth
attacking me Jon Snow that was terrible
[Music]
Jon uh what's his name Jon Snow and
Harrington Harry can you you come also
upon release it was just on PCs on ps4
now as well I think it's only like 20
bucks so fortunate that the beginning of
so slow like that I know there's been a
couple games this year with that what if
you were that stipulation of like okay
you just gotta get past this first extra
time thing and then and like I think
that there's some there's a benefit to
that like that
careful set up that a lot of these games
like then knock down yeah uh but it is
it's a hard sell for a lot of people if
I hear SAS ins Creed is one of them but
it's even I mean for that game it's like
an hour-ish is when things start like
really moving but what am i hearing like
10 hours for SAS ins creators the intro
I'd kind of thrust you into the world
pretty early on but it just doesn't
always introduce like the potential of
it as well cuz I love that game but it
yeah I would say it's like a few hours
in Assassin's Creed all right Pete all
right Marv IP rest in Peter what's one
of your games but both the games I
picked came out way earlier this year
I'll start with maybe the less obvious
one gravity rush to not sway out the
game that nobody talks about you shut
your mouth
just kidding yeah I mean literally I
nobody brings up gravity rush to ever
and it's really a shame because it's
it's a sequel to a game that began in
the handheld it was like remastered for
consoles and and it was a quaint kind of
little experience where you manipulate
gravity and you fall and that is
essentially flying but it's this weird
tumbling effect and that lets you really
just interact with the world in ways
that you just don't in other games but
gravity rush to really really expanded
upon the character the world she's in
the story of her involvement and her
abilities as well and it kind of
packages it all in this tight little
like season of anime if I remember
correctly it's like everything's broken
up into like little episodes and there's
like 24 episodes you know it's like it's
it's just it's packaged so well it looks
so good it plays so well it has very few
flaws and I don't really know why more
people didn't play this game because the
first time I set eyes on the first game
I was like wait a minute I can just fly
anywhere like the top of that tower I
can just hurl myself at it or I can walk
in that scene like that's pretty cool
and it feels every bit as awesome as
you'd think and there are some issues
with I'd say some of the ways that the
game asks you to interact with those
powers but by and large this is a
incredibly unique experience and it
again I'm just dumbfounded that one
people haven't played it it came up
earlier in the year right yeah it also
had that super cute live-action
commercial with the cat that walked on
the ceiling oh and I don't think you'd
think that advertisement would work Yeah
right
I really really wholeheartedly recommend
this game I gave it a 9 which I think a
lot of people in the office were
surprised about but you know like
looking back at that today so many other
outlets gave this game a 9 I wasn't I
was far from an outlier in terms of the
reception of this game I think it's
Metacritic is like 85 or something like
that I mean it is awesome and I just
play it the flying looks just reminds me
of like a dream it's like this weird
it's not how you visualize flying you
know what I mean like it is it's like so
differently and
that in and of itself can be worth a
half an hour in this game just exploring
the world like it's it's the most basic
form of movement in this game like even
like running requires more of you than
this does like you know like running and
steering and watching out for things
like this just lets you just fly and
it's so easy to pull off
it feels effortless cool all right Kelly
let me go back to you okay I think I
know what the other one is but go for it
I just really really want to spotlight
stardew valley on switch yeah Ravi you
were you were gonna talk about this but
Kelly beat you to it yeah you took it
but someone's gotta take it uh yeah I
think I feel a little weird about it
because the this game was out on other
platforms last year but I do think that
the switch is the best way to play this
game and my one reservation is the long
load times which they've said are going
to improve with a later update but
that's like the one hiccup in an
otherwise like it's such a good
experience for the portability of the
switch and I I really can't understand
that I know that doesn't sound like it
would be the most important thing but
when I played it on PC last year I found
myself always wishing I could just take
it into bed take it into like my comfy
chair because this is a kind of game I
wanted to relax and escape into and you
know just enjoy the you know the
pleasures of the valley and that's
something that playing on PC or on you
know on ps4 or Xbox just didn't provide
so playing it on the switch has been
phenomenal for me yeah like it is the
portability factor for sure like in for
me it's like I'm watching TV I'm zoning
out while I'm playing it I'm like like
making breakfast or something like that
like there's somebody who said about you
know with PC or you know I'd say more so
a PC like that's kind of an investment
always right like you're sitting on and
you it's like you look at your watch I
got having to play for like this long
like there's some about just like
putting this down on a couch and like
getting up it's and it's frankly one of
those addicting games I played in awhile
where it's like yeah
oh I'll just I'll just water these
plants ran I'll be done oh I'll just do
one more day and then it turns into five
more and I really hate for ya right as
I'm talking about the good aspects of it
being on switch I haven't really sold
the game itself which is that I think it
really blends a lot of almost disparate
elements so there's like the RPG like
almost like min maxing elements at this
game but also the relaxed don't don't
like you're you're you're in star D
Valley to escape the the rat race like
day-to-day grind of an office job is
like how to steam opens grandpa left to
and grandpa left you the farm and so I
know a lot of people really min/max
their farms and that's something that a
lot of people have a lot of fun with but
I also have been enjoying and that's
something that I do in games and I'm
very perfectionist when it comes to
games like this but in many ways the
Sardi valley encourages me to step back
from that and just kind of like try not
to be worried about
oh just I plant the right amount of
crops and did I you know did I maximize
my efficiency rather you kind of just
you know every day is different you can
go to the mines you can it in many ways
because there's so many options
encourages you to let go a little bit of
that like just the fact of there are
seasons right like I remember the first
time when I was playing in like just
going from I don't know summer to fall
or something like that but it was like
you just walk out the door and oh all my
crops are dead like when you see that
you're Jesus alright start again I guess
like that was a such a curveball I did
not know that was like a factor I'm just
doing all this planning like I'm gonna
have a great year it's one of those
games really I was way too fixated on
when I was playing on PC on how to play
it right yeah and there are definitely
ways you can play it correctly like you
said mid maxing so you get your green
house before your first winter which I
actually did yeah and I'm not at that
point yet and I played maybe like 60
hours or something but I do like that I
can just play how I want to it won't
matter really I mean there will be
penalties every once in a while but
you'll also it won't really matter the
grand scheme of things yeah and like
yeah just definitely I think PC is you
you get on your PC you're like alright
here's what I'm gonna do for the two
hours and
this game I get this stuff done we
switch I'm like all I want to do is fish
like I just I I think if you have a
switch you should absolutely even if you
played stardew valley pick it up for the
switch there's one thing I gotta say is
as far as sound effects goes in that
game you milk cows obviously but with if
they're how do you say they're not
producing and they don't have their
utter lists isn't like us milking cows
terrible for their otters no cows need
to be milked yeah but by their like
their their calves
yeah probably abs legs their babies not
like Josh Shaw's in the twitch chat and
he was just kind of freaking out cuz he
put in I forget how many hours you
started I was talking about mid maxing
Josh Shaw has these images of like look
at my bar I saw his cranberries yes
cranberries you just see what he's done
it's literally machine we were joking
like the farm or the towns it's like
dude factories like Josh walking around
yeah show us his bank account of what he
makes in a day that's like I don't know
50 grand
people can make like 50 grand a day
whereas like I'm like I'm starting a
winery and I like make a bunch of wine
for fun yeah Josh you said you should
see my basement which out of context is
a creepy it probably has a ton of kegs
in his base yeah brewing burning stuff
or wine you should see my face that wine
yeah alright Rob would love to keep
talking stardew but yeah Josh thought it
was 800 grand I don't know anything
maybe a day per day audibly yeah right
with starfruit wine for sure was at the
top - your wine just chill out Josh
chill out dude
like anyone thought game Peyer is
another game this year that was a
surprise for me
surprised you mentioned it yeah it was
on my game of your list
damn well that's alright fantasy I
really really like that game like it's
one of those
cases of just every aspect every every
aesthetic in this game is like top-notch
in my opinion like the writing the the
sport of this game in a in itself is
really fun and gripping and the writing
is is great like I think most people
have this similar experience we were
like you know you I think early on you
gosh what was his name the kind of like
cat died IOT thing Roxy Rock Bruce Bruce
Kherson like that yeah anyway stop
bringing up trivia they don't know he's
got a moustache and he's like we think
my moustache it's rookie donkeys he's
like we think my moustache and you have
the ability to tell him to like shaved
or not and he just like either white
right I think I throw him a shave and he
was like super embarrassed and that was
just a really cool moment of like you
know your your impact and your care your
care and attention to this team you kind
of develop is really genuine especially
later on we have been there I mean you
could probably without spoiling too much
you do have to make difficult decisions
later on the game of your team as well
and that can change the narrative to
like really high stakes at play that
don't really seem apparent at first it's
the sport itself is like an arena for
them to get out of purgatory and kind of
ascend back to the real world right if
I'm not mistaken correct but you know
you use sins you know a character it
seems really deserving of going back to
the real life crap they're also your
best player so you send them back then
maybe your team is weaker and then you
might lose games you might not be able
to send anyone else back the next time
and it's like gosh what do i what do I
do here yeah yeah this game was really
fun I mean like obviously supergiant
made Bastion and transistor as well and
I just you can kind of see it come
through in the art style but was really
interesting how they took kind of like
the sport genre and added these RPG
fantasy elements to it kind of a new
twist on it and it was I think they
really paid off this was what do you and
I think we're on summer I believe so
yeah July August maybe and I think it
might even post e3 because I'm ever
playing that I want to play it more I
know
few people on her staff we're talking a
lot about it the last few weeks yeah
Ruki ryouki I don't even know how you
said you have rookie Ruki I know there's
like I'm gonna pin Burpee to the Peter
the the like that opposing group of like
the same type of like creature he is
yeah forget their names too but they're
just like these like the classic like
dumpster dumpster alley cats like hey
buddy like you want to go and be a
worthy Alley Cat yeah the character yeah
so many great little touches even just a
little like audible emotes they do like
when characters start to chime in those
do a really great job of just selling
these like still portraits as characters
and then obviously the characterization
through the writing works really well
it's cool
phenomenal game mmm awesome what about
the PvP do you guys play much against
each other
yeah a little bit it's good it's
definitely sort of I could see like if I
didn't buy many games a year maybe I
would play that like if I had him you
know if I was growing up with siblings I
could definitely see that going down
yeah I didn't dive into it too much we
played a good amount like it was
definitely like engaging but yeah it's
it's it's kind of a I would say a slight
bummer that it's not online but then
again like I don't know that's not the
game like the game really is like the
single-player experience all right Pete
what other games supposin Peters
no no you liked it though I give it a 9
9 points out of 10 points well-deserved
gamespot.com
all right Yakuza zero is my second game
and that should come as no surprise yeah
I've said so much about this over the
year but I feel like I could keep going
go for it
the y-axis is zero is just a is just an
unabashedly goofy stupid but also like
oddly touching dramatic game it knows
how to wield like you know high stakes
situations really well and it knows how
to just use itself as the butt of its
own jokes
so it's just this constant just had been
flow between those two different
attitudes and it works so well and it's
it is a primitive game
look at the way it plays it is not
sophisticated at all but that that I
don't know that works to its favor but
at least it doesn't necessarily harm the
game too much it can get a bit
repetitive with the combat but that's
like the worst thing I can say about it
beyond some of the things that tie into
Yakuza culture which is ready bit G this
is just the overboard objectification of
women which look don't jump on me for
being as just aw even though I am I'm
just saying this game gives you softcore
porn and it is treated as valuable as
the rest of the game which is fine if
you want to do that but playing on a
live stream holy [ __ ] was that mr.
libido
[Music]
dope yeah you find this guy he's just
walking around in his underwear all the
time and no clothes yeah what was his
name was something like I wanted to say
it was like mr. innuendo
mr. erection but it wasn't that no
walking erection yeah it's it's a weird
game that has a lot of heart and
depending on your tastes you find
something for you in it and it's just
cool too because we also got Yakuza
kiwami this year which is you know this
is zero is the prequel to the entire
series which has been around since the
PlayStation 2 and this set the stage for
the remake of one in kiwami and we got
six coming out early next year kiwami 2
coming out later next year an
embarrassment of riches don't seem at
like not actually kill anybody is this
the game where you just beat the [ __ ] on
them yeah oh yeah I mean you drive a
motorcycle through their skull but they
get up and thank you for the privilege
of being on the receiving end of a beat
that's an experience you can't get
anywhere else you know it's true there
is something to be said too about the
setup so like almost every fight it is
like just earlier we saw the guy was
like you like you ready [ __ ]
like into the face and you know you're
also you play this two different
characters in two different cities and
these are not Grand Theft Auto scale
cities by any means they're like ten
blocks by ten blocks but the characters
are very different and they're in it but
they feed into a singular narrative very
well super soap opera over alright very
silvery
but like again it's when that is
violence and money and property and you
know ruling and it's just I don't know
all that stuff is just kind of
interesting it just strikes such a
perfect tone for all of that like I just
love it like I think I brought it up
before in the lobby what my favorite
moment is when like he's super
dramatically answers the phone and it's
like this animation of him reaching for
the phone and it slows down and he picks
it up and goes much more and I just the
tone is so right for like the
over-the-top violence and sex and money
stuff yeah it feels like a product of
the 80s and that's when it's set and
that's just kind of cool that it that it
all works together it doesn't feel like
someone trying to cobble together an
understanding of that time it feels like
oh god yeah here we go
84 just relax in the game and it
definitely feeds into the overall like
quirkiness of it it's just to see how
far it takes it like this isn't just
like a one-off you think you have like
30 videos to collect or something like
that
you got something during collectibles
yeah there's 30 of them yeah and it's a
goes all day it's for teens my favorite
let's be honest it's for fun yeah if it
doesn't it's not for it and that's cool
like that's fine vortex Ian in the
twitch chat was asking is no one going
to mention the freaking karaoke
that's because pretty rad - so is the
disco dancing in the bowling and the
batting cages and the arcades and the
darts like Saturday Night Fever there
yeah absolutely there's so much you can
do this is so funny when it's like
because I'm telling this like dream
version of what you're doing
I but like being in this small
hole-in-the-wall bar and there's like
two people in the room and it's like
someone else singing because there's
different types of karaoke and you're
just there
that's pretty much it we did our what
about you oh yeah I mean I don't know
what games do I want to talk about Fire
Emblem echos shadows of Valencia's one
of my favorite games of the year which
kind of caught me off guard
I love turn-based in general turn-based
strategy but the feeling it kinda
reminded me of Suikoden - what I was
telling you you're kind of building up a
massive army not as big in Fire Emblem
there's like a hundred something
characters you can get in Suika Suika
done but fire bloom echoes I really
really enjoyed it was a turn-based
brought me and they erased kind of the
relationship aspects of awakening or
fates that a lot of people like and I
went back to wake and I do like how
they're implemented but I liked it
without it for you Echo's is such a good
entry to the Fire Emblem series
especially because it like strips away
those extra things and then you can get
into something like awakening coming
from like an ex-con background I think
and I do also like pray a lot mmm a ton
that was one of my favorite games of the
year it's as far as like what it does
for kind of not bringing back immersive
Sims because there's like been around
like breath of the wild has a more
system elements and it's not going
anywhere but I do really enjoy how they
made it a singular level as far as
arcane Studios is concerned some of
these discrete levels in Dishonored 2
we're going mission a mission and kind
of using each individual sandbox this is
one big sandbox you can kind of have a
different experience based on next
person like I know Pete you had a
different experience in Callie did and I
found the shotgun like six hours in the
game whereas John we've got it like an
hour in yeah and like I I played that
game when it came out and I haven't
really played it since but I still have
kind of a map in my mind of like I can
still see where everything is yeah
really got into that yeah I like how the
story unfolded almost remind me not just
cuz it's not a Space Station in a
singular setting reminds me of Tacoma in
the way that each part of the space
station which is tacomas another great
game I guess we can talk about but each
part of the Space Station has its own
distinct flavor that you kind of
remember and ties in a narrative and
then you go back to it with a different
nurse standing later on but speaking of
Tacoma
obviously gone home was kind of a
monumental game I'd say for video games
obviously like it's
it didn't spawn but it kind of sparked
the big wave of walking simulators which
is later was embraced as an actual term
much like punk-rock I guess they kind of
started using it used to be this
derogatory thing but you know what
remained of what remains of Edith Finch
came out this year I finally played that
I liked it a lot but I think Tacoma was
really cool about how like the setting
can affect the story and the characters
you can see how characters act
differently based on where they are it's
not just these diary notes you're
picking up but you can hear this
character talking to someone else in
this room and then hear one side of
things then you hear her go away and
like talking to another character in
another room and you hear a super
different kind of take on everything and
then you hear one character agree to
something and then go back and like
record a message to his son back on
earth and like he's like I just lied to
them so holy [ __ ] yeah I Tacoma is
interesting because I think it has such
a cool concept and I think it's
implemented so well until the end like I
didn't I didn't get like the
satisfaction of the ending that I wanted
from that game but I would love to see
more things with that the idea of like
the AR people yeah that you can interact
with and I did really enjoy the
storytelling I just didn't feel like the
ending was like I just was missing
something for me I reviewed that game so
if you want to know more you can read
through the characters overall act
authenticity like no one was walking
away like burping or farting is like
I've been hold that in for what that
would be good that's that we all operate
right to come yeah it's coming was a
very interesting game I liked it a lot
it's certainly like as you were saying
the proximity of people and getting to
witness how that all played out was
super interesting it could have gone
further yeah yeah they um they were
inspired by a sleep no more the stage
production in New York where it's like
an interactive not interactive but it's
a play where you get to walk around and
experience different parts on your own
so cool really cool I did a while ago
before like gone home came out I forgot
when I saw it was gone home would have
been 2013 13 thank you and like I think
I did Sleep No More a year before that
or something it's really cool if you're
ever in New York and it's still running
I'm not
sure if it is you go check that out if
you're into these kind of games they
were inspired largely by something like
that I gotta ask are you not gonna bring
up pub G at all no i yeah i guess i'll
bring up pub G that's actually the one
game that obviously we didn't connect
smite you know where you might not like
consider as an early access game but as
an early access game I love that game so
much I mean Jake you you played a few
rounds I think you got a chicken dinner
and like your second one because someone
carried you Matt Nick plays a lot
Michael hi I'm playin Janka that game is
so any Battle Royale game I think the
appeal of that sub-genre whatever you
want to call it is that the rules are so
simple but like you can imagine the kind
of permutations that come out of it and
that's where pop G becomes fascinating
and that's why there's so many like
highlight reels around pub G because
people will do something and it's it's a
simple game a simple looking game it you
know like the servers are very clean for
the most part for such for so many
people playing it I think I forgot how
many they cross broken oh really oh I
didn't have the narrative lately is that
there's so many cheaters oh that has
been I think they recently actually
addressed that I saw it had news about
that but that aside I been djenka said
something to me yesterday that I really
liked and it was like for a game that's
designed for most people to fail or most
people to lose the fact that it keep
like you still want to play it and still
like want to take on that challenge
again and again is really impressive and
I just like I didn't really think about
it that way so I was like feeling really
we had a lot of bad games last night I'm
just feeling really shitty like I
dropped into the school I punched a guy
to death and then I immediately died
they're like okay well I wasn't last but
like that game is designed for most
people to lose John Luke I understand ok
this was [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
because I was in this game I mean it
wasn't [ __ ] I'm very proud of John
Luke but like I I died like super early
and I had to watch for 30 minutes as my
team went on to get a chicken dinner
without me and I was like I failed my
team's
got it though but they did it John Luke
got the last shot too it's really good
yeah this is something cool happens this
game more than anything is okay friggin
Jake curling away it's fantastic about
more than anything in a second it's
promising like what can people do with
this genre in the future as well I mean
because this is not the first one to do
it obviously this spawn from Daisy which
is you know like then there's h1z1 and
thereafter and actually apparently it's
actually kind of good I didn't play much
yeah
is that I say probably said a fortnight
right battle royale is apparently
actually pretty good I know a few people
that play a lot Lloyd Christmas who's a
friend of the show always like I think
he was enjoying it for a while see the
school where I'm dead don't it's backing
up to him yeah come here come here
yeah it's getting fantastic and one of
the few one of the good really good at
early access games dead cells also which
is still in early access which is more
of a not procedurally generated Judi
Dark Souls
yes add/update like TV so yeah dead
cells that was gonna be and hollow night
is one more game I want to touch on all
right for people who can't see the
gameplay we were just talking
incessantly I'm sorry observer observers
fantasti of cyberpunk dystopian we're
talking to coma and I was think I may
I'm so cool if like that
rewind investigative narrative from like
Tacoma was in observer cuz observer got
all he had I think I had so many things
going for it but like one of the things
that got a little tedious was like you
just going up to doors and you're
listening like someone talked like that
over and over but the aesthetic and
everything about that game like that was
like kind of you basically you're a
detective and you like Jack and like
Dead or Alive people and go through like
they're probably dead that's just my
preference alright and it's it's pretty
surreal what you like kind of like go
through like it's like horror ask really
people are saying that's like the
perfect cyberpunk game this year
people were saying it yeah but it's got
its kinda man it's got execution issues
for sure there's kind of jagged around
the edges yeah which is fine you could
say that's part of the experience but I
didn't know like the guys the main
characters vo yeah those are skis shall
I suck with it you know it's been a long
year yeah
really quickly if you haven't played
danganronpa
yet dong around one to reload came out
this year and dog around three came out
this you just could play all three of
them and I'm still getting revelations
about the story it's so good I love
dying around so much I'm too niche for
most things though that's all I just
wanted to plug it really quick yeah you
play holiday as well I think that'll pop
up on whatever lists but it's a
Metroidvania kind of to B reductant to
be super reductive but it's a in this
pretty haunting world it like very
attractive art style just black and
white I found it attractive but in terms
of people liking games more and more
recently like breath of the wild where
they kind of just don't give you much
direction or hold your hand this game
you can be exploring for a long time in
this two-dimensional open-world and then
meeting new characters and figure out
how to move forward and combat feels
great or at least I think it feels great
for that kind of game reminds me of
rogue legacy in a way which is one of my
favorite games play hollow and I should
check it out that was really excess all
of last year right or even part of this
year and then it released good question
Michael no I'm telling you it with us oh
yeah sorry
I just said it with a little too my
voice all right so that's pretty much
the lobby for the day in the week and
the year
jean-luc I usually thank you guys the
end the episode but kind of put me on
the spot here I'm switched back to you
guys in the back room so you guys can
get one last oh it's just him pretty
much make sure the show make sure this
show works he lets me talk about prey
and X come to as much as I want and he's
always there to make sure the show is
produced well Richard Lee and Eric Tay
are always in the back as usual thank
you everybody who's been joining in the
YouTube chat all year Eric green 84
gesture ex Liz James the list goes on
and then twitch as well obviously goob
Josh Shaw
No Mas is always there great to meet him
at e3 this year he came to our live show
but yeah we don't really fully you have
a road map for next year of the lobby
and our live show stuff I think we're
gonna have some sort of big meeting to
see what we want to do once game of the
year stuff calms down figure out how we
want to move forward with it as far as
maybe with some changes we want to make
the structure the identity whatever I
don't know but you'll still probably see
our dumb faces on camera in one way or
the other from time to time it's just on
location around the country oh that's
good I don't say we should all have like
like food and we're eating
I would not annoy me hearing that stuff
and the mics no that's the worst not
only quit the show I would quit
I would leave I would move quit yeah I
forgot about the giveaway Mega Man
headphones that's what it is
pretty cool actually I was look hot yeah
you follow a GameSpot on Twitter gonna
retweet the page for that at the end of
the week in a few days we'll pick a
random winner from the pool of people
who retweeted if you're in the twitch
chat Shiva usually puts the link in
there and then again just go to GameSpot
for the link and just following you
spawn sweater between the link all that
Star Wars comes out in like what 8 days
is it 8 they lessen they're 16
oh my god Thursday I see ya with Josh
Shaw and chat cool I excited
yeah it looks terrible not saying it
looks good so I mean if you want sorry
more about what we're doing for game of
the year but yeah seem out saying yeah
so that's Thursday night is when people
will be seeing oh my god far away we
tell them one of our games what I
thought you almost just announced well
no no we were talking about what we're
seeing Star Wars jean-luc is seeing it
at 12:45 at midnight meaning it's a
three hour movie basically I don't know
I would just can't believe some of the
people who are seeing movies I think I'm
seeing it like 11 p.m. oh my god I don't
see this do you have one a.m. what are
we seeing it 10:30 yeah I'm seeing at
1:00 a.m. don't you
spoil anything for me or text me yeah
I'm sure I'm deleting Twitter for my
phone yeah but as far as Dean of your
stuff goes starting Monday December 11th
at 10 a.m. Pacific we're gonna announce
our number 10 game of the year and then
subsequently count down from there each
and every day of week day so it'll be
ten nine eight seven six weekend five on
the monday and that on the 18th
our number four game will be Tuesday the
19th and then on the final day December
20th our final day before the holidays
and the last day of game of year we're
gonna now it's three to one right in a
row so you don't have like a full day
where you can maybe figure out what 2 or
1 are so will be kind of like
shotgunning those on that last day but
yeah they're all set in stone
XCOM XCOM 2 is up there again it's not
my fault but everybody loves that game
so we just put it at number 1 again
sorry whoops I didn't mean to tell
what's number that's kidding so again
thank you to everybody joining
throughout the year go check out that
giveaway we'll be back and we'll keep
you updated on future plans for the
lobby until then we'll see you around
our game of the Year livestream starting
Monday
[Music]